[Music]
do
[Music]
welcome to session 58 of the worlds of
speculative fiction series this is a
monthly series that began as
face-to-face meetings back in 2006
went online due to covid in 2020 and has
been continuing on more or less monthly
the name of the series kind of gives it
away it's about speculative fiction
authors
and the narrative worlds that they
develop in their stories or novels or
pick whatever else it's going to be
usually we're talking about more than
one book we're usually talking about a
series by an author although sometimes
there are exceptions to that
and what we do is we look at the author
their biography what they have to say
about their work what other people have
to say about their work and then we
concentrate
on the narrative universe sort of
spelling it out what are the key
elements of it and we look for
philosophical themes that we can explore
now we follow this up with a zoom
conference right after this video
premieres during the video premiere we
have live chat so i interact with people
about that and that is a substitute for
the original meetings that we had for a
number of years at the brookfield public
library which were face to face sitting
around a table talking about these sorts
of things
now session 58 is focused on philip
pullman's his dark materials trilogy i'm
not going to be going into the later
books that are set in the same narrative
universe why because i haven't read them
you notice that i did spring for the
boxed set
of
three books
uh the one that gets it all going
phillip pullman the golden compass right
and then uh the subtle knife
slightly shorter than the the other one
and then the big thick one book three
the amber spy glass each of these
identified with a particular artifact as
we'll talk about and bringing in a
character whose engagement with that
artifact is going to be particularly
important for the entire
narrative universe so um i'm going to
say a few things just before we jump
into talking about philip pullman's
biography and his corpus of works and
then we'll do some talk about uh the
narrative universe or rather universes
the multiverse involved in this and i'll
say that i had very low expectations
heading into this because you know i i
take suggestions from
fans of uh and participants in this
series every year about who we should do
next and i usually have some pretty
clear ideas myself about who i want to
do and this was a fan favorite people
kept saying oh you got to do phillip
pullman you've got to do his dark
materials you're going to really like it
and i think
i i was
leery about that in part
because of the what's apparently kind of
a
off-base
movie adaptation of it that was done and
i saw you know advertisements for that i
read some write-ups of it and i was like
i don't know that that's the sort of
thing i actually would be interested in
doing it sounds kind of like you know
cheap reductive
easy writing sort of sort of thing
hitting the the notes that young adult
fiction usually
aims for the you know the and i don't
mean the good young adult fiction i mean
the shoddy kind of stuff that uh floods
the market and
i will say that my experience with these
books was the exact opposite you know i
started of course with the golden
compass
began reading it and you know i was like
wow this is very readable and you know i
kind of like what's going on here this
is quite interesting these characters um
this is this is compelling fiction and i
got hooked and i read my way through it
in just a matter you know in my spare
time a matter of a few days and then i
was like wow i gotta read the next one
and so i went on to the subtle knife
where new characters are being
introduced the world is being widened
the scope of the narrative is being very
expertly worked through and i was like
holy crap this is some good stuff and
then we get to the final novel and i
couldn't wait to find out what was going
to be going on here and i plowed my way
actually didn't plow my way i ran my way
through it because it was so enjoyable
and you get to the end and it's kind of
a bittersweet ending i won't give away
the absolute spoilers
about it we'll just say that you know it
does involve these two characters of uh
will you know who is is brought out in
the subtle knife
and um
you know lyra who is
mentioned on i think yeah the very first
sentence of this lyra and her demon
diamond move through the darkening hall
so there's some really cool stuff going
on there
i am a big fan now and we've been trying
to watch our way through the hbo
adaptation which seems pretty decent
unfortunately hbo doesn't play well with
with amazon tv so sometimes it doesn't
actually work
but these these books are certainly
great and i'm going to say this
before i jump into
like the the presentation proper there
there are there's two things i want to
say one is
these are essentially pitched as um
young adult y a novels
they certainly can be read by young
adults by adolescents i would even say
perhaps by
smart
elementary school students
but they're not just young adult novels
these are
really well
worked through and
can appeal to
older adults 50-somethings like myself
who know a lot of the reference that
that pullman is bringing up and
we can find a lot of
great adventure great tension great joy
great sorrow i found myself getting
quite emotionally invested in these
characters and in what was going on with
them as i read through the stories the
other thing i'm going to say
is that
maybe one index of the quality
of a work is that after you've read it
once you also want to reread it again
not every work that i've
read and talked about for worlds of
speculative fiction actually
fits that but these these certainly do
i would definitely in a year or two i
want to have some space from them
go ahead and re-read them and i think i
would probably enjoy the narrative
even more even though i know what's
coming up it's that kind of work it's
that kind of
literature it's not dependent on
revelations it's dependent on the
storytelling itself and i imagine that a
second read
would be a deeper read would catch more
things that are
woven into this story in matters of
style and matters of foreshadowing in
matters of how well the narrative is put
together so
let's talk now about philip pullman
himself
phillip pullman is an author who is
currently still living writing working
and engaging
a vast public i'm going to keep the
biography section a little bit shorter
than i usually do in part because
there's so much other things i want to
get to but there are some very important
aspects of his life that i think
we want to know about in order to make
sense out of this narrative world
and it's you know key aspect so i was
very interested to find out that he was
born the same year as my own adoptive
parents in 1946
he's born in norwich england to audrey
pullman and albert
alfred pullman who's a royal air force
pilot and because of that they end up
traveling around a good bit including to
southern
rhodesia
he's educated in england in rhodesia
that time now zimbabwe australia and his
father is going to end up
dying in a plane crash in kenya
posthumously he'll be awarded uh the
distinguished flying cross and pullman
himself in interviews talks about how at
the time he thought his father was a
great hero and then later on he finds
out that actually he was you know
engaged in strafing these guerrillas who
really couldn't do much in response the
mao maos and there were some intimations
that perhaps the crash was
something deliberate
in any case
they wind up settling in wales
in um
harlach gwened and spending time also in
in norfolk with his grandfather
so the family is continuing on and he's
getting educated as a matter of fact in
one interview he talks about
deliberately losing his london accent so
he's not getting beaten up by the welsh
boys suddenly he changes his tune
from his grandfather who is a clergyman
he discovers john milton's paradise lost
and that's going to have an important
effect on him
you know he goes through schooling there
in 1965 he goes to oxford attending
exeter college oxford like several other
schools there's an entire assemblage of
different colleges that you can go to
and and pulpin says i i didn't actually
do that well in school
you know i i got sort of i thought it
was not quite the lowest marks but
that's because they discontinued some of
the lower marks he got a third class ba
they were no longer offering fourth
class in
1968. in 1970 he discovers william blake
and his illustrations and his writings
this like milton is going to be a big
influence upon him that's also a very
important year for other things in 1970
he marries judith speller who will have
two children with
and he begins teaching
children at bishop kirk middle school he
winds up teaching at other places as
well and these children are ages 9 to
13. so what here in the united states we
would say sort of the end of elementary
school the beginning of middle school or
even junior high
and
he's teaching for quite a while and he's
also writing school
plays
um
after that between 1988 and 1996 he also
taught part-time at westminster college
oxford continuing to do his writing so
this entire time he is you know carrying
out a life he's doing his his writing
and different projects and by 1996 he
can begin writing full-time he can you
know leave behind this day job you could
say and he writes a lot of things in the
course of his career which is still
going on children's novels short stories
picture books things specifically for
children he also writes plays and novels
comics some non-fiction things and
there's two sets of stories and novels
that we want to pick out um he writes a
series of of four
sally lockhart
novels about this young victorian
adventurer the ruby and the smoke in
1985 the shadow in the north 1986
the tiger and the well 1990 the tin
princess 1994 so you can see he's got a
good series going and then he adds to it
over time
and then we have the series that we want
to talk about here his dark materials so
this begins
in 1995 with northern lights which is uh
in its uh uh american version the
golden compass right and that's uh
followed in in two years by
the subtle knife in 1997 and then three
years later by the amber
spyglass so you know well spread out
thing but it doesn't stop there there is
a currently uh
ongoing series the book of dust which
picks up afterwards belle sauvage in
2017 the secret commonwealth in 2019 and
then there's what are called companion
books lyra's oxford in 2003 once upon a
time in the north 2008 the collectors
2014 and most recently serpentine and
these are adding more and more to
the storytelling
there's a lot that happens in the course
of his life that that's quite
interesting and you can see that he's
he's being honored he's also making some
very important commitments so let's talk
about some of the honors that are taking
place 2007 he's made an honorary
professor at bangor university uh in
2009 he's actually ordered the degree of
doctor of letters honoris causa by the
university of oxford being recognized by
his alma mater and in 2019 he's actually
knighted for service to literature so
he's actually sir philip pullman
he also
does a number of other things
for example in 2013 he was elected
president of the society of authors very
important british distinction
you know in 2008 he hosts the writer
table for the waterstones bookshop chain
highlighting 40 books that have
influenced his career he also gets
invited to like edit grims fairy tales
uh 2009 he becomes a patron of the
palestine festival of literature and
this is a good segue into talking about
his his political and cultural
commitments
he writes for the guardian quite often
particularly about education
critical of of the education policies in
britain and in other places
he also continues um engaging the
literary world so 2008 and 2011
he does 2014 as well he does a couple
important interventions 2008 he leads a
campaign against age bands on the covers
of children's books saying you know what
do we mean age bands well you know ages
four to six or ages 12 to 15. and
pullman says this is a really bad idea
we shouldn't do this it's based on a
one-dimensional view of growth you know
you're seven now so you read these and
then a whole bunch of other people join
the campaign booksellers illustrators
librarians teachers
he got his own publisher scholastic to
agree not to do that anymore
he also backs a campaign in 2011 to stop
a number of library closures and i love
this line he calls it a war against
stupidity and you know we often take
libraries for granted they are such a
wonderful resource that we have that
many places in the world don't have
access to so keeping libraries open
something he was very passionate about
in 2014
it had to do with gender he he was
involved in the let books be books
campaign to stop children's books being
labeled as either for girls or for boys
and he says i'm against anything from
age ranking to pinking and bluing whose
effect is to shut the door in the face
of children who might enjoy coming in no
publisher should announce on the cover
of any book the sort of readers the book
would prefer let the readers decide for
themselves this is a principle that he
will go back to over and over again
and you know
one of the the tragedies that happened
in britain in an avoidable tragedy is
the grenfell
tower fire he in fact
in the second book of dust the secret
commonwealth he includes a character
named after one of the victims of that
that tower fire nur
huda al-wahabi and as part of the
charity auction
authors for grenfell tower he offered
the highest bidder a chance to name the
character in the upcoming trilogy
raising over 30 thousand pounds in the
process so you can see that he is we're
just mentioning a few things here he's
very much somebody who is not an ivory
tower
type he's very committed to thinking
about our society that we live in
and you know that draws quite a bit of
fire and i think the last thing that we
should mention
before we jump into everything else
is the adaptations of his dark materials
right so there's currently an hbo
adaptation that seems to be fairly
faithful we've only watched a few
episodes to the actual books but there
was also a you know movie
version labeled the golden compass which
you could say took a lot of the
fangs out of his his literary
presentation and effectively
christianized the book which he was or
christianized the movie
based on the book which is not something
that that pullman himself was happy with
because
he does have a very strong commitment to
a certain kind of atheism that we'll
we'll talk about a little bit more
elsewhere where it's relevant so that's
the biography so far just some thumbnail
sketch of it
we learn quite a lot about what authors
have in mind in working on their book by
reading what they have to say in
response to other people
about that and in some of the past
videos that i've done i think i've
lingered a little bit too much over
reviews and so in this one i'm just
going to confine myself to interviews
that were done with phillip pullman that
touch on important aspects of this
trilogy and where he's coming from
as a writer so the first topic
has to do with these being viewed as
children's literature or as young adult
or any of that sort of uh classification
and in a
slight interview that was done 20 years
after the release of
northern lights or the golden compass he
is asked
we talk a lot about young adult fiction
and who reads it and why is the golden
compass young adult fiction what makes
young adult fiction different from
regular adult fiction and his answer is
it's a very complicated question i don't
know whether the golden compass is a
young adult book or a children's book or
an adult book that somehow sneaked its
way into a children's bookstore i don't
actually think about the audience i
don't think about my readers at all i
think about the story i'm writing and
whether i'm writing it clearly enough to
please me
if you asked what sort of audience i
would like i would say a mixed one
please children keep your attention on
the story because you want to tell it so
clearly that nobody wishes to stop
listening
and the adults remind you not to
patronize or underestimate the
intelligence of the children so that's
you know kind of an interesting way of
framing what he's doing in another
interview where a bunch of school
children wrote into him with questions
and they said you know how old is the
reader that you're aiming at he said a
reader my age
he's writing to himself
in another interview in the new yorker
he was asked
i gather you continue to think highly of
adolescence which is not everybody's
opinion
and pullman says well it's an
interesting time when i became a teacher
i was teaching children who were 11 to
13 that sort of age their lives were
beginning to open out in terms of
intellectual curiosity in terms of
emotional maturity in terms of physical
changes it's a complete earthquake of a
time
and i've always thought it was very
important it's the change as william
blake puts it so well between innocence
and experience and particularly in the
third book we find that you know um the
main characters will and lyra are
approaching
their adolescence the point where their
diamonds are going to become fixed in
one state
or another they're shifting around all
the time until then and by the end they
they do adopt
forms that they're going to
have
the interview continues saying that's
one of your great themes going back to
inno between innocence and experience
but one thing that occurs to me is that
sometimes teenagers can have a kind of
nostalgia for their childhoods even
though they're not that far removed from
them it's the dawning of an awareness
that for the first time they're moving
past an age or a period of life they're
not going to be able to recover
philip pullman responds
i suppose that happens
but
most kids i think look forward rather
than back they want to be grown up they
want to smoke cigarettes and get drunk
and have sex and they want to have a bit
of money and drive around in cars
it's only when you're kind of mature
maybe in your 40s or when you've got
kids yourself that you think oh wouldn't
it be nice if i could go to bed and have
a story read to me and then just go to
sleep without having to get up and go to
a job in the morning
the nostalgia
is an adult thing
not a childhood thing
i think these are interesting
ways to
think not just about what pullman has to
say about childhood adulthood but to
think about the work that he's
doing and whether these are in fact
children's stories that are being you
know
also multi-purposed as adult stories or
whether there's something different
going on there
and then you know in in other interviews
he brings up other fantasy writers or
rather these are pitched to him
um so
in the uh 20-year slate interview he's
asked you said you're not a huge admirer
of c.s lewis or j.r tolkien both of whom
have written fantasies that in some ways
resemble the golden compass is it fair
to say that these books have a somewhat
didactic relationship to readers now a
didactic relationship this is something
that we were supposed to avoid when i
was young and we were doing writing
because didactic was kind of a bad word
meaning that you're trying to like teach
people along the way you're preaching
rather than telling a good story so
what does pullman say
they're often bracketed together tolkien
and lewis which is
i suppose quite fair because they were
great friends both oxford writers and
scholars both christians
tolkien's work has very little of
interest in it to a reader of literature
in my opinion when i think of literature
dickens george elliot joseph conrad the
great novelist found their subject
matter in human nature
emotion in the ways we relate to each
other
if that's what tolkien's up to he's left
out half of it the books are wholly male
oriented the entire question of sexual
relationships
is
omitted tolkien was catholic which meant
for him
that there were no questions about
religion the church had all the answers
but lewis was different he was a
protestant an irish protestant that that
from a tradition of arguing with god and
wrestling with morality his work is not
frivolous in the way that tolkien is
frivolous though it seems odd to call a
novel of great intricacy and enormous
popularity frivolous i just don't like
the conclusion lewis comes to after all
that analysis the way that he shuts
children out of from heaven or whatever
it is on the grounds that one girl is
interested in boys she's a teenager ah
it's terrible sex can't have that and
yet i respect lewis more
than i do tolkien now him saying that he
respects lewis more than he does tolkien
is
not saying oh token failed to measure up
to this lofty level that lewis was at he
doesn't particularly like lewis and in
the high profiles interview he says
lewis is a contradictory sort of
character for me i loathe the narnia
books and i loathe the so-called space
trilogy because they contain
an ugly vision
but when he was talking about writing
for children and about literature in
general lewis was very very acute and
said some very perceptive and wise
things as a critic
and as a psychologist the screwtape
letters for example is full of very
shrewd stuff about what it's like to be
tempted i rate him very highly but i do
detest
what he was doing in his
fiction so you know some some
engagement with the previous people that
he's being compared to
um in the the uh
uh interview uh the 20-year slate
interview the
interviewer says to move on to someone
who you respect quite a bit
milton there's so many parallels between
the golden compass and paradise lost
lord austria must be satan right with
his starry name and ambition and dark
magnetism then there are all the
meltonic similes and the bear fight and
witches sometimes playing the role of
the angels what other miltonic easter
eggs should we look out for do you have
a favorite one and
pullman says well the dark materials is
of course a retelling of the miltonic
temptation and fall but most of that
happens after the golden compass ends
what i wanted to do is represent the
fall as entirely good it is good for
people to know things to grow up to
become sexual beings which shows that
he's doing something different than
milton in many respects the the
interviewer followed up and said how
conscious of milton and that story
were you when you were actually writing
and he says well it wasn't a sentence on
sentence basis but you mentioned
miltonic similes and those were
deliberate illusions
the epic context demanded there be a
certain epic quality to the language i
didn't get close to milton though and
there was never a moment in the writing
process where i felt oh i've got that
wrong i'd better change it it is my
story
and i'll do what i want with it i
remember the words of william blake
i must create my own system
or be enslaved by another man's and i
think that's that in effect what is
happening here in the world building
creation of other systems and a vast
cosmic system as well
in the new yorker interview
he um
you know he's being asked about religion
and he says
it was when i became a teenager and
started reading for myself that the
faith fell away but that didn't mean
that i sprang into the world as a
militant atheist
what i'm against is what william blake
called
single vision being possessed by one
single idea and seeing everything in
terms of this idea whether it's a
religious idea
or a scientific idea or a political idea
it's a very bad thing we need a
multiplicity of viewpoints so i'm
perfectly willing to entertain the
prospect of the secret commonwealth this
world of fairies ghosts witches and so
on
side by side with the world of reason i
wouldn't want to be governed by one or
the other
and again i think that's what we see
depicted in these books
interestingly in the high profiles
interview
somebody says a lot of people assume
from the amber spyglass that you must be
an atheist the amber spy spyglass of
course being the final and largest of
these novels and he says well they can
assume what they like
of course i won't i don't say there is
no god i say
there is a god and here he is dying and
this is what i was most particularly
pleased with as a result of an act of
charity and he goes with a sigh of the
most profound and exhausted relief
and then he says the interviewer says
but god is an impostor
he's the first angel
who is himself the accidental byproduct
of the meaningless universe the
interviewer says and now here's where
pullman says something i think really
quite important and interesting
it's not meaningless
it was meaningless before but it's not
meaningless anymore this is the mistake
christians make when they say if you are
an atheist you have to be a nihilist and
there's no meaning anymore
that's nonsense as mary malone discovers
now that i'm conscious now that i'm
responsible there is a meaning and it is
to make things better and to work for
greater good and greater wisdom that's
my meaning and it comes from my
understanding of my position it's not
nihilism at all
it's very far from it and we should
pause here for a moment and think about
this you know is this framed in a kind
of nietzschean way we just saw that he
says that god is dying right and he
mentions god dying of supreme charity
right that sounds like the dying or dead
god in friedrich nietzsche nietzsche
thought that nihilism is indeed the
problem of the 20th century and i'd say
it goes on into the 21st century as well
as the central problem what do we human
beings do when the highest value
devaluates itself well
one response might be to acquire power
to you know express the will to power to
become the ubermensch right
another is a little bit more
down to earth saying
we don't need to do all of this
wild crazy stuff i mean we can fight
against heaven if we wish to but we
might also think about
fulfilling our duties
recognizing what the right thing to do
is and then doing the difficult work of
sticking to it once we've committed to
it and that is what will and lyra and
seraphina and so many other
characters do in this story
so i think that's
you know quite profound there
in the
textualities interview he's actually
asked
have you ever yourself had any
experience
that could be described as a state of
grace or mystical
and pullman says yes yes i have not very
often i may add probably only three or
four times it has to do with seeing
things more clearly
mystical experience is sometimes
described as a cloudy state when the
real world dissolves for me it's not
been like that or else what i've had has
not been mystical experience what i seem
to feel
was that i saw the connections between
things much more clearly much more
visibly vividly there were patterns
there were correspondences there were
shadows here of something there
everything was connected with enormous
excitement i could see that the universe
was alive and i was part of it
i saw this so clearly and intensely i
don't think i could sustain that state
for very long so you know pullman is far
from a militant atheist all of this is
you know for an attack of british all
this is rubbish no he he doesn't take
that point of view
and i think that his point of view is is
compatible with
say people like william james or george
santayana or other figures
perhaps even with with people like
kierkegaard or gabriel marcel
he's asked again in that interview do
you think there is such a thing as
wisdom
he says yes yes there is and it it is to
do with that sense of the connection
between things and the meaning of things
which is the same actually the meaning
of something is its connection to other
things the more connections you see the
more meaning you see so that again very
interesting
point of view um
now there there's a few other things
that he says that i think are worth um
bringing up in the slate interview uh
20 years he said with 20 years of
hindsight is there anything you would
have done differently if you were right
rewriting his dark materials
he says no
those works are complete actually i
wouldn't change the first two
with the amber spy glass the final one i
would have liked to have taken another
six months
but so many people were writing me and
begging me hurry up hurry up
i don't feel that it's a bad book though
i'm i'm happy with it so that is really
i mean if you think about the capacity
for us to tinker around with things
almost indefinitely that's a sign that
he feels that this is a really
solid
set of of works
finally the last thing from the lit hub
interview
i think this is a great way to end this
little segment was there ever a moment
when you felt the story
started telling you
now this is a little complex notice what
he says here
yes to an extent it did there are things
a story wants to do and things that you
want to do
and in the end the story wins because it
knows better than i do there's an odd
sense that one is discovering
rather than inventing
there's a sense in which the story
almost seems to be there in some
platonic realm
and what i must do is try to transmit
that pure sense to paper
rather than go in for any clever stuff
of my own it's curious
because i don't actually believe in
platonic realms of pure being
yet writing feels more like discovering
rather than merely going along with a
literary construct that's only made of
words so i do believe instinctively that
it is all it is in fact all out there
somewhere and i'm just writing it down i
can't justify that at all
but there it is so that's you know
something like a platonic realm that he
doesn't actually believe in philip
pullman you could say is rather of an
empiricist he wants to see what's
actually there and to not
pre-judge ahead of time no no this can't
be this this can't be this you know
either atheism or christianity you can't
you know
he's a pluralist he's in some sense an
empiricist a radical empiricist like
william james is and he's bringing
together
elements and ideas and thematics that
are drawn for example from milton or
from blake who he brings up all the time
but he's creating something new of his
own in the process
it's time now that we talk about the
narrative world or rather worlds
a multiverse that we find developed
within these three novels by philip
pullman
and
one of the things that we can say
that i think is actually a strength of
the work is that pullman
does a good bit of world building and
exposition within the novels themselves
without spelling out too much
so he's sort of like ursula k
le guin
in how she develops you know earth-sea
and you know we get to see a glimpse of
bits of it in the first novel and then
there's more and more that she develops
and she says that well you know i made a
map first and then i started thinking
well what goes on over here and what are
the people like over here what kind of
stories can i tell uh with pullman what
we get is it's centered around
characters and their interactions and we
get to see the world through
what they say or
what they experience or what they're
doing
and at first we don't actually
get to see much of this multiverse as a
matter of fact we never get to see an
awful lot of it because so much of it is
just tara incognita unknown land or
rather unknown worlds and even in the
worlds that we do know much of it
remains
unknown as well
so things begin in the golden compass
and this is a world that has oxford for
example which is like our world right
but it's developed differently there's
important
differences between
that world and our own world and some of
these have to do with like you know who
are the inhabitants of it there's an
entire race of witches for example
there are
polar bears that speak and think like
human beings but have their own bare
nature and put on their armor which is
like their soul and you know all sorts
of interesting
different features like that history has
gone a good bit differently
there are you know
things that we can reasonably identify
but the you know
the
political situation that we're used to
we can say also the situation of culture
and education
is considerably different
there is a group of people who are sort
of modeled off of the roma
the egyptians who you know are sort of
wandering people who have this network
all over the place and they get you know
involved in a very important way as well
and within that world there is something
called the magisterium
now we would normally associate that
with the catholic church wouldn't we
interestingly john calvin in this story
has been a great leader indeed a pope of
the magisterium and the magisterium is
what people have imagined the catholic
church to be like in a global sense that
it's only been like in
local senses you know like when people
think of the inquisition right which by
the way provoked a lot of uh discord
within the church itself you know
whether we're talking about the spanish
inquisition or the german witch finding
inquisition the uh the
the vatican was not super happy about
what was going on there but imagine like
some of the worst stereotypes of of the
church or specifically about like say
the jesuits or the inquisition and there
you've got the magisterium they want to
keep control
over things and there's as we're going
to find out an entire backstory
about the supernatural being that's and
beings angels and god that's being
referred to
in all of this and so that's that's an
important aspect
you could say that there's there is
technology of of all sorts i mean a
golden compass the truth meter right the
al al theomator uh that plays an
important role in this um there's you
know fire firepower that can be turned
against uh
people and there's balloons and all
sorts of cool stuff going on
but
things are things are different
um so
experimental theologians there are what
we call scientists here
in our world
and by the time we get to the end of
this work what we find
is that um
lira's at first uncle actually father
is engaging in a great experiment
trying to break the
walls between the worlds and he succeeds
using some some super
great power
to
do that her father is going to try to
destroy as we're going to talk about the
essence of
dust later on
we'll we'll discuss what dust is when we
get to philosophical themes
and
her father is going to breach
what the
aurora borealis has been showing us and
not the the veil between worlds the
aurora borealis
looked at in the right
lens
you can see cities
beyond
the clouds
so that's an important aspect that's all
happening within this novel the gateway
has opened up there
and her father goes through
lira goes through as well and finds
herself
in another
world another dimension which is not
radically
different
but is uh different enough
from the world that we're
inhabiting which is where the second
novel
begins
the second novel begins
um
with will tugging his mother's hand and
saying come on
um
you know he's essentially
not abandoning his mother but giving her
over to this piano teacher mrs cooper
and saying you need to take care of of
her for a while i'll be in touch when i
can
and we find that that will
makes his way
through
into a gateway into another dimension
and this is where lira
is and they meet up and there's you know
things going on between them right um
there's other things happening in lira's
world that she's now left so now we have
three worlds going on we have the world
of our world
we have this other place the
city that's set in a
basically italian setting and then we
have lira's original
world and
with the knife we find out that you can
cut
into other dimensions
and that's what will ends up doing
we
wind up
going into a number of other worlds
sometimes just as a sort of
dodge because the topography of the
worlds preserves a certain continuity to
each other you can cut a hole over here
go 10 paces that way cut a hole step
back into the world that you were
originally from and you've gone 10 paces
so that's a really important
uh
aspect to it
the worlds get even more complex and
varied when we get into the amber
spyglass where we pick up a
third
we could call her a main character right
somebody who is brought up in the the
first
story all right and um
[Music]
you know she's she's mary uh former nun
and
she is going to be
going into yet a different world
one more evolution
has actually worked
differently
than um
our world
very very differently in in the
the fact that
there are creatures who don't have a
central
spine
they are
in kind of a diamond shape with their
bones and they are not only sentient
they are
intelligent creatures so intelligence
has arisen in many different forms in
many different places
mary malone right and so she is becoming
another
main
character and um the world that she
lives in is another important one but
then
there's yet an even more interesting one
will
and lira
are going to go down
or go to the world of the dead
where it is that souls go
after a person has died and they have
left behind their diamond
and
um they are now moving into a different
realm where they're tortured by harpies
and there is no escape from it that is
also part of it will
manages to open up a gateway back to
the other worlds
for the dead who are going to exit this
this immense
land of the dead as well and why do they
go down there well because roger
lira's friend has been communicating
with her through her dreams and he's
stuck in the land of the dead he was the
one whose
connection to his diamond furnished the
energy
for opening up the portal that you know
lord israel
lear his father originally did in in the
the first book towards the end of it
and what we have are all these
interconnected dimensions and worlds
the knife has been able to open up a lot
of portals will the knife wielder can
also close the portals as well
and it turns out
opening up all these portals
created what we might call
i mean i'm tempted to use the word
ecological crisis
but perhaps that is
not a
big enough term usually when we think
about ecology we're thinking about like
the entire planet right of earth and
we're saying let's take a big picture
approach a long-term approach all these
interconnected systems and we need to be
careful about them or if things get out
of balance we need to try to figure out
how we can rebalance them or we move
from one you know key era to another
through the massive paradigm shifts we
might be in the middle of one people
call this the anthropocene right now
where we've managed to really disrupt
the these you know the the world that we
live in
but that's only one world
if we're talking about
multiple worlds then
is the word ecological
even even the right word we need
something kind of bigger like a
multiverse ecological i don't i don't
know what what we should call it maybe
people have good suggestions about that
but there is a crisis that is happening
across all the different worlds
a crisis in addition to the other crises
that are happening like you know in
lira's world it's getting warmer and the
polar bears are needing to find a place
to to migrate to because their homes are
starting to break up um the dust itself
or the dark matter
or
uh you know all the other things that
it's called in these other worlds are
going to different places and that is
disrupting for example in the world that
mary goes to where there are these
intelligent creatures that have a
relation with a particular tree the
trees are no longer getting
fertilized and they're dying because the
dust is flowing away flowing out of that
world into a
void right so there's a lot of stuff
going on
ultimately
the story becomes
uh well there's several things entangled
there right we have the uh
i'm gonna overthrow
the the god the deity that was set up to
be like the thing that the magisterium
is supposedly worshipping and in the
place of that lord asriel and his army
are doing um
there's some you know some really
interesting stuff going on there that
we'll talk about
there's also
you know warring going on in in other
ways people trying to control this
and there's this sense of
we need to fix what's happening or
everything is going to
fall apart and everything that's great
within the
not just world but the universe the the
multiverse is going to die out including
this intelligent dark matter you know
the dark materials uh perhaps being
referenced there the dust that has been
uh generated and played such an
important role
in all of these worlds and their
development so there's there's a lot
going on
with the worlds that we're exploring
here i'll just wrap up by saying this
we're dealing with a multiverse in which
there are many different kinds of
sentient creatures all of whom are
essentially
given some some place some sketching out
by philip pullman human beings are
really at the center of things but
there's many others that play central
roles as well
one of the very interesting
philosophical themes that runs
throughout this entire trilogy and you
might say throughout the entire world
not only of lyra but also our own world
has to do with these dye bones and we
see it in the very first line of the
first chapter of the golden compass lyra
and her diamond move through the
darkening hall taking care to keep to
one side out of sight of the kitchen
and we also find out something else
about diamonds right the diamond speaks
to her you're not taking this seriously
whispered her diamond behave yourself
her diamond's name was pantalaimon and
he was currently in the form of a moth a
dark brown one so as not to show up in
the darkness
of the hall they're making too much
noise to hear from the kitchen lyra
whispered back and the steward doesn't
come in until the first belt stop
fussing
but she put her palm over the ringing
crystal anyway and ponce limon fluttered
ahead and through the slightly open door
of the retiring room after a moment he
appeared again there's no one here he
whispered but we must be
quick and
everybody in in well
actually we should be careful about
saying that because there are going to
be some people separated from from their
dymones later on in the story but
generally everybody has their dimond and
we learn
throughout this this work that the the
diamonds do something very important
they
are you know assume all these different
animal shapes shifting from one to the
other until
a certain point in a child's life when
they're moving into adulthood they take
on a fixed shape and people get the
diamonds as we find out in the golden
compass not necessarily what they want
but what it is that expresses them
because the diamond is
them it is part of themselves that has
been externalized it is
a portion of their soul you might say
right that's the way it is for people in
this world now we do find out that there
are ways to separate a diamond away from
a person
this gets done to soldiers to make them
into something like mindless automatons
it also is being done to children up in
the north the oblation board
actually run by lira's mother is
carrying out experiments to do this sort
of thing lyra almost has this happen to
herself and it does happen to her friend
roger uh generating the energy which
which breaks the the gap in between
worlds and we we hear something really
gruesome
about
what diamonds end up you know in some
cases having to do
early on in the story
they're talking about the breathless
ones
and who are these warriors half killed
being alive is one thing and being dead
is another but being half killed is
worse than either
they can't they just can't die and
living is altogether beyond them they
wander around forever they're called the
breathless ones because of what's been
done to them and what's that lyra asked
wide-eyed the north tartars snap open
their ribs and pull out their lungs
there's an art to it they do it without
killing them but their lungs can't work
anymore without their diamonds pumping
them by hand
the result is that they're halfway
between breath and no breath life and
death half killed you see and their
diamonds got to pump and pump all day
and night or else perish with them you
sometimes come across a whole platoon of
the breathless ones in the forest
sometime right so this is a very
interesting thing to to bring up the
daimongs
you know they help to keep you alive
they look out for you but if you die the
dimon disappears into
dust as well so it is you
and there are a number of different
what we could call i mean they're called
taboos having to do with the diamonds
you're not supposed to touch another
person's diamond the diamonds themselves
will you know scrap with each other or
you know caress each other do whatever
they're going to do but you're not
supposed to touch another human being's
diamond and it's not just human beings
themselves who have them it turns out
that the witches also have them
and the witches can
have their diamond go somewhere else the
witches are always birds like a goose or
a red
or whatever and the dimon can operate
independently whereas for ordinary
people
the dimon can't go that far from you
without you feeling
a real sense of unease at first and then
physical
pain within yourself there is one
exception to this
and this comes up you know in it well
with lira's mother and the ablation
board um
there is a scene
where um
this golden monkey who is her her
mother's diamond uh mrs coulter's uh
damone
is um
off doing its own thing
actually poking around
in in her room and so you know that's
that's kind of an exception is her
mother kind of like a witch her she
certainly somebody possessed of a
very strong personality as is lira's
actual father
uh lord azrael and
you know um they both have very powerful
damones
there's another conversation that takes
place as well
which is quite interesting
that we should reference and that
happens in the golden compass too
when uh lira is is talking with as it
turns out the king of the bears who
is um you know
working in in a metal shop and and
drinking and stuff like that in exile
from his his kingdom
um
she is going to
ask him
you know about his armor and the the
armor that a bear has which they make
themselves
is sort of an analog to
the
[Music]
to the soul the diamond that a person
has except as lyra points out there's a
very important difference you can make
your own armor right you can't make your
own diamond you're born with it
so those are some really interesting
things that that come up and then you
know in the subtle knife we encounter a
guy from our world who does not have a
dimon at least we think and that's
that's will and
what we do find out
is that
um
you know here we go lyra says
she could see the intensity in his body
saw his jaw working saw an authority to
send over it calming relaxing and
clarifying
the authority was will's own or his
diamonds perhaps how he must miss
having a diamond the loneliness of it no
wonder he'd cried and it was right of
pontal pantala meown to do what he'd
done though it felt so strange here when
when he touched will right
and
as it turns out will and everybody in
our world does in fact have them they're
just in us
rather than
out there visible
agency in in the world and we're going
to find out in the third book
the amber spyglass when
will and lira and several others descend
to the land of the dead
that
will does in fact have a diamond
so they're at this
this place with the boat man
and the boat man is going to um take
lira across but
there's a price a terrible price that
has to be paid
so will got in first then lyra came
forward to step down too but the bolt
men held up his hand not him he said in
a harsh whisper not who
not him he extended a yellow grey finger
pointing directly at ponte
whose red brown stout form immediately
became irma irmine white but he is me
lyra said if you come
he must stay
but we can't we die isn't that what you
want
and then for the first time lyra truly
realized what she was doing this was the
real consequence she stood a gas
trembling and clutched her dear diamond
so tightly that he whimpered in pain
they said lyra helplessly then stopped
it wasn't fair to point out that the
other three didn't have to give anything
up
will was watching her anxiously she
looked all around at the lake at the
jetty at the rough path at the stagnant
puddles the dead and sodom bushes her
pan alone here how could he live without
her he was shaking inside her shirt
against her bare flesh his fur needing
her warmth impossible never
he must stay here if you
are to come the boatman said again
and
he says uh
if she comes he has to stay will said
that's not right
we don't have to leave part of ourselves
behind why should lira and here's where
we get a revelation
oh but you do said the boat man it's her
misfortune that she can see and talk to
the part that you must leave
you will not know until you were on the
water and then it will be too late but
you have to leave that part of
yourselves here there is no passage to
the land of the dead for such as
him
and what we find is that will does in
fact have a diamond and it's
it's left behind on the pier and it
feels awful for him and you know
eventually
what we find later on in the amber spy
glass after they make it out of the land
of the dead is their dimons are
reluctant to come back to them it takes
a long time for them to be
rejoined but
the diamonds also
are off spending time with each other
and that may be part of i mean you can
say there's a reflection
of the
growing love that will and lyra
have for each other
there's also this you know beautiful
passage a very martial passage where
lyra's mother and father
are fighting against uh the you know the
head angel himself who is essentially a
serp the place of god
and
their um
you know daimones are
helping out and also you know connected
up with each other as they they take the
angel down killing themselves in the
process
i mentioned that there was this
separation
of diamonds physically from from people
and that is how you generate these these
soldiers that essentially have no will
any longer
that's being done to some of some of the
people within
these these stories so this is a really
key theme there's a lot more that could
be said about it but this notion of
seeing oneself outside of oneself being
able to have a conversation with oneself
the
unloneliness that that happens because
of that
and actually pullman in an interview
does say that when he first began
writing this
lyra didn't have a diamond
this is something that comes about later
and it
so
enriches it that you almost can't see
these books without thinking
of that uh here the last thing i should
say about the diamonds is that there is
an evil kind of being the specters who
feed upon adults and what they're
actually doing is consuming the adults
daimones and taking away their
will their agency their
who they are their identity so there's
there's a lot uh happening with this
particular theme developed in these
books
one of the features of the narrative
universe in
going on from the golden compass onward
is what's called dust it's called dust
in lira's world it's called dark matter
in our world and it's called other
things in other worlds as well and it
plays a really central role one that
we're not
cognizant of
early on and i i think you could say
it's not even clear by the end of the
golden compass just how important and
what
dust is
there's a lot of theories about it being
put forward it's also a topic that
you're not supposed to bring up
but we don't really know what's going on
with it until we start getting into the
later two books particularly the third
one
and i should mention
that the amber spy glass you know we've
got the golden compass the you know
allayah theo mentor right the truth
telling thing we have the subtle knife
which opens up portals between worlds
and then we have the amber spy glass the
amber spy glass is actually something
that mary puts together that allows her
to see
dust that allows her to see
what is going on which the um beings of
of the universe that she's in can can
see as well and the first reference to
dust is very early on it's in the second
chapter of the golden compass
lord azrael is having them take a look
at some some photographs that he's taken
and we see that he says i'd like you to
take a look at another one taken from
the same spot only a minute later with a
new specially prepared emulsion he
lifted out the first slide dropped
another into the frame this was much
darker it was if the moonlight had been
filtered out the horizon was still
visible with the dark shape of the hut
and its light snow-covered roof standing
out but the complexity of the
instruments was hidden in darkness but
the man
had altogether changed he was bathed in
light and a fountain of glowing
particles seemed to be streaming from
his up raised hand that lights of the
chaplain is it going up or coming down
it's coming down
said lord osriel but it isn't light
it's dust
something in the way he said it made
lyra imagine dust with a capital letter
as if this wasn't ordinary dust
the reaction of the scholars confirmed
her feeling because lord azrael's words
caused a sudden collective silence
followed by grasps of incredulity
and so
he says it's dust lord azrael repeated
it's registered as light on the plate
because particles of dust affect this
emulsion as photons affect silver and
nitrate it was partly to test it that my
ex
exposition went north in the first place
uh and now the the question is
who cares what's so important about this
dust stuff well a little bit later on in
the story what we find out
is that there's a
you know reference to it you could say
this is talking about the uh world of
spirits and other worlds and the witches
and um
father koram asks you know what's going
on with the aurora she and john fuzz
talking and john foss says
is this thing of the aurora anything to
do with dust and the goose diamond says
all i can tell you is that the dust
hunters are as frightened of it as if it
were deadly poison that's why they
imprisoned lord asriel
and and she says but why
here's the answer they think he intends
to use dust in some
some way in order to make a bridge be
between this world and the world beyond
the aurora now that's not what actually
happens
uh something else is going to make that
bridge but you know the magisterium is
really quite afraid of what people might
do
about dust and then towards the end of
that book we find out there's this whole
interesting back story lira asks
what's dust why is everyone so afraid of
it
and uh
you know she's she's talking here um
about the you know elaiathometer right
and he looked at her as if trying to
guess whether she would understand what
he was about to say he'd never looked at
her seriously before she thought now
she'd been like an adult and until now
he'd been like an adult indulging a
child on a pretty trick but he seemed to
think
she was ready
dust is what makes the late theometer
work
ah i thought it might but what else how
did they find out about it
in one way the church has always been
aware of it they've been preaching about
dust for centuries only they didn't call
it that name but some years ago a
muscovite called boris mikhailovich
russokov discovered a new kind of
elementary particle you've heard of
electrons photons neutrinos all the rest
they're called elementary particles
because you can't break them down any
further there's nothing inside them but
themselves well this new kind of
particle was elementary all right
but it was hard to measure because it
didn't react in any of the usual ways
the hardest thing for rusikov to
understand was why the new particles
seemed to cluster where human beings
were
as if it were attracted to us and
especially to adults
children too but not nearly so much
until their demons have taken a fixed
form
during the years of puberty they begin
to attract dust more strongly and it
settles on them as it settles on adults
now
all discoveries of this sort because
they have a bearing on the doctrines of
the church have to be announced through
the magisterium in geneva and this is
this discovery of russocos was so
unlikely and strange that the inspector
from the cons consistorial court of
discipline
suspected rusekoff of diabolic
possession they performed an exorcism in
the laboratory he interrogated rusekov
under the rules of the inquisition
finally they had to accept the idea that
if the fact that russokoff wasn't lying
or deceiving them dust really existed
that left them with the problem of
deciding what it was
and given the church's nature there was
only one thing they could have chosen
the magisterium decided that dust was
the physical evidence for original
sin
so dust is being misinterpreted by the
magisterium
as you know what
what what reflects original sin the sin
of adam and eve
we learn a bit more in the subtle knife
there are some other important
discussions and
passages right and the most important is
where lyra
and dr malone mary meet up
dr malone
is engaging with these things that are
called
the shadows
right
and lyra comes in there and they're you
know talking
lyra tells her that the alley theometer
works by dust she came all the way to
find out more about dust and it told me
to come to you mary so i reckon your
dark matter must be
the same thing
as dust
and there's a computer set up that
allows them to communicate
with the
dark matter or the shadows as dr malone
is calling it
dr malone says the room's full of
shadows the universe is full of shadows
come to that but this is the only way we
can see them when you make your mind
empty and look at the screen
off you go
and so she's working with the la
thermometer
mary malone will realize that you can
actually use the e jing as well
and lyra is saying is this dust is this
the same thing making these patterns and
moving the needle of the allele
theometer she's asking that to the
allele theometer she's communicating
with the
dust
dr malone says you've just put on the
best display i've ever seen that's all
what were you doing what were you
thinking
i was thinking you could get it clearer
than this clear that's the clearest it's
ever been but what does it mean can you
read it and
malone says you don't read in the sense
of reading a message it doesn't work
like that what's happening is that the
shadows are responding to the attention
that you pay them
that's revolutionary enough it's our
consciousness
that they respond to
you see
then there's you know
messages going on the screen responded
as quickly as thought itself and out of
the welter of lines and flashes a new
set of pictures formed with perfect
clarity compasses alpha and omega again
lightning angel each picture flashed up
a different number of times and then
came a different three camel garden moon
lyra saw their meanings and unfocused
their mind her mind to explain what it
says it's saying in my language the
language of pictures but what it says is
you could use ordinary language too
words if you fix it up like that you
could fix this so it put words
on the screen
but you need a lot of careful figuring
with numbers and the lightning meant
anabaric i mean electric power and the
angel that's about messages
and maybe there's a way
they have in my country of talking to
dust i mean shadows same as you've got
here with pictures only their way uses
sticks so this is the e jing reference
and mary malone is actually going to
begin
talking through the computer
with
the dust with the dark matter with the
shadows
through
the computer and then she has to she has
to flee uh and she
in effect actually flees
to
another world
the world that is discussed in the amber
spyglass well one of the world's disgust
and now we learn more about dust right
we learn about it at first
through an angel
it turns out there's all these angels
and uh will is talking with with baruch
and um
baruch says i think you we should tell
you our information this is why we've
been seeking you why we must take you to
lord azrael we discovered a secret of
the kingdom of the authority that's
god's world and we must share it with
him are we safe here there's no way
through
and so he says tell me then said will
tell me about metatron who's almost
attacked them right
uh and what this secret is why did that
angel call him regent and what's the
authority is it god
he sat down in the two angels their
forms clear and the moonlight that he'd
ever seen them before sat with him
balthamos said quietly and this is a
major revelation
the authority god the creator the lord
yahweh el adonai the king the father the
almighty those were all names he gave
himself he was never the creator he was
an angel like ourselves the first angel
true the most powerful
but he was formed of dust
as we were are
and dust is only a name for what happens
when matter
begins to understand itself matter
loves matter it seeks to know more about
itself and dust is formed the first
angels condensed out of dust and the
authority was the first of all he told
those who came after him that he had
created them but it was a lie one of
those who came later was wiser than he
was and she found out the truth and so
he banished her we serve her still and
the authority still reigns and the
kingdom and metatron is his region so
we've got a lot of different themes
working out there right we've got this
you know origin of god as not really
being god it's kind of a agnostic story
except that there's no like total escape
to even a higher god or anything like
that
we've also got this notion of what we
can call emergence right
matter becomes conscious of itself that
is dust it becomes conscious and loves
itself and the angels the original
angels are formed of conglomerations or
whatever it's going to be
of that and the first of them
lies to the later ones about
his very origin
all right so we've got two really
important themes
overlapping here right
there's more to tell about metatron and
the
you know
the authority and all of that but we'll
skip that and jump ahead to talking more
about dust now the church the
magisterium in in lyra's world
is um
very concerned with dust and they're
having a big meeting
and they say
fourthly dust i've taken steps to find
out what the ablation board has
discovered about it because one of the
things in the magisterium there's all
these agencies working at cross purposes
with each other
one of the experimental theologians
working at
bulvangar has been persuaded to tell us
exactly what they discovered
i shall talk to to him this afternoon
later and
now
the president says
whatever we do learn about dust we must
bear our purpose firmly in mind the
ablation board sought to understand the
effects of dust we
must destroy it all together nothing
less than that if in order to destroy
dust we have to destroy the oblation
board the college of bishops every
single agency by which the holy church
does the work of the authority then so
be it
it may be gentlemen that the holy church
itself was brought into being to perform
this very task and perish in the doing
of it but better a world with no church
and no dust than a world where every day
we have to struggle under the hideous
burden of sin better a world purged of
all of that so we've got
you know lord asriel thinking he can use
dust to break through we have the the
church saying we need to get rid of dust
we have uh you know mary and
lyra and will and many others coming to
realize that dust is something
incredibly
important getting rid of it would
actually be a big problem it's not
something you can exploit
and much much later on
um after the the you know the amber
spyglass is actually formed that allows
mary to see these incredible
you know
currents flowing through the air and
around the living beings
we find out about the ecological
or
trans world ecological crisis
of dust that has been going on and this
is going to lead us to
something very
important later on so
mary
gets out the spy glass through it she
saw two quite different movements in the
sky
one was that of the clouds driven across
the moon in one direction
one was the other was of the stream of
dust seeming to cross it in quite
another
and of the two the dust was flowing more
quickly and at much greater volume
in fact the whole sky seemed to be
flowing with it a great inexorable flood
pouring out of the world
out of all the worlds into some ultimate
emptiness now that's a big problem
because
for the world that she's in the dust
fertilizes these trees that these wheels
are are found on that the intelligent
species the uh you know who use these
wheels and their oil to to live their
their existence right
all of this is going to go away if dust
goes away
so she says slowly as if they were
moving themselves in her mind things
joined up
will and lyra had said the subtle knife
was 300 years old at least so the old
man in the tower had told them
the malefa the this intelligent race
told her that the sraf which had
nurtured their lives and their world for
33 000 years had begun to fail just over
three hundred years ago
according to will the guild of the tory
deglianjelli the owners of the subtle
knife had been careless they hadn't
always closed the windows that they had
opened with the knife mary had found one
and there must be many others
suppose that all this time little by
little dust had been leaking out of the
wounds the subtle knife had made in
nature
the subtle knife was responsible for the
small-scale low-sk low-level leakage it
was damaging and the universe was
suffering because of it and she must
talk to will and lyra and find a way to
stop it
but the vast flood in the sky
was another matter entirely this was new
and it was catastrophic and if it wasn't
stopped all conscious life would come to
an end
as the molecular had shown her dust came
into being when living things became
conscious of themselves but it needed
some feedback system to reinforce it and
make it safe as the malefic had their
wheels and oil from the trees without
something like that it would all vanish
and now this shows us the
depth of the catastrophe that's
threatening them thought
imagination
feeling would all wither and blow away
leaving nothing but a brutish automatism
and that brief period in when life was
conscious of itself would flicker out
like a candle in every one of the
billions of worlds where it had burned
brightly so this is this is a really
significant insight and this is a really
significant problem as well and what we
find
is that
there we go they are
talking about this this entire issue
and pan
lyra's demon reveals to them something
about these
portals that have been opened up
pan says it's about dust and will marvel
to hear part of his own nature
it was will's demon telling him
something he didn't know it was all
flowing away all the dust there was down
into the abyss that you saw something
stopped it flowing down there but
well it was that golden light lyrics or
the light that flowed into the abyss and
vanished and that was dust
yes but there's more leaking out all the
time ponte lymon went on and it mustn't
it mustn't all leak away it's got to
stay in the world and not vanish because
otherwise everything good will fade away
and die
but where's the rest leaving from said
lyra
both diamonds looked at will and at the
knife every time we made an opening said
kirjava and again will felt that little
thrill she's me and i'm her every time
anyone made an opening between worlds or
the old guild men anyone the knife cut
into the emptiness outside the same
emptiness is there down in the abyss we
never knew no one knew because the edge
was too fine to see
but if it was quite big enough for dust
to leak out of if they closed it up at
once there wasn't much time for much to
leak out
but there were thousands that they never
closed up so all this time dust has been
leaking out of the world
and into
nothingness so what is what is the
response that they have to have for this
the understanding was beginning to dawn
on will and lyra
every opening lyric said in a whisper
every single one they must all be closed
said will every single one said
pontalaimon whispering like lyra oh no
it can't be true and so that is what
they in fact have to do close up every
single
point of contact every slippage between
the worlds to preserve dust in there so
what is this dust this is what gives us
consciousness what gives us as you know
he said a little bit earlier in it what
gives us feeling what gives us thought
what gives us imagination what gives us
our affective and cognitive and
intellective powers
this is what's what's being revealed is
something that emerges out of matter
itself something kind of miraculous but
also something that obeys its own
laws
this is the dark
material you could say although that's
taken from a bit of poetry that lies in
this entire world
of this trilogy
and so that's a really absolutely key
theme
a third great philosophical theme in
philip pullman's trilogy of the dark
materials is the force of
love love between
lovers love in many other ways but i'm
going to focus here
on that between lovers specifically
lyra and will
and that between her mother and
father which
generated her and then split them apart
and then they come together towards the
end of the amber
spyglass and there will be some
spoilers here because i can't really
adequately
talk about this without going into the
what happens to the love between will
and lyra before that though
we have this this
face-off between metatron the angel
who is you know speaking on behalf of
the authority who's kind of behind the
scenes running the show
and um the two
lovers of mrs coulter and lord asriel
who had you know sired uh lyra who have
been you know
at cross purposes
so often
they are going to team up along with
their diamonds and fight metatron to
drag him
into the void where they can destroy him
why so that they can give lyra some some
time and space to accomplish what they
need to do
and so there's this this wonderful
scene here
[Music]
he took her into his arms and the golden
monkey embraced the snow leopard's neck
and berry to his black face in her fur
is lyra safe as she found her diamond
she whispered the ghost of the boy's
father is protecting both of them dust
is beautiful i never knew
what did you tell him thinking about
metatron i lied and lied ezreal let's
not wait too long i can't bear it we
won't live will we we won't survive like
the ghosts not if we fall into the abyss
we came here to give lyra time to find
her diamond and when the time to live
and grow up if we take metatron to
extinction
marissa shall have that time and if we
go with him it doesn't matter and lyra
will be safe yes yes he said gently
he kissed her she felt as soft and light
in his arms as she had when lyra was
conceived 13 years before she was
sobbing quietly when she could speak she
whispered i told him i was going to
betray you and betray lyra and he
believed me because i was corrupt and
full of wickedness he looked so deep i
felt sure he'd see the truth but i lied
too well i was lying with every nerve
and fiber and everything i've ever done
i wanted him to find no good in me and
he didn't there is none but i love lyra
where did this love come from i don't
know it came to me like a thief in the
night and now i love her so much that my
heart is bursting with it
all i could hope was that my crimes were
so monstrous that the love was no bigger
than a mustard seed in the shadow of
them and i wished i'd committed even
greater ones to hide it more deeply
still but the mustard seed had taken
root and was growing
and the little green chute was splitting
my heart wide open and i was so afraid
that he'd see
a little bit later he kissed her saying
lyra will be safe and the kingdom will
be powerless against her
call him now marissa my love
so they call him and they fight and they
go down into the abyss
together
and then afterwards uh not too long
afterwards
we find out that uh
what happens with them
and there's a discussion here about love
between will
and and lyra where um
[Music]
here we go
they're talking about his father um the
witch killed him he had never really
understood that he explained what she'd
told him before she killed herself she
loved john perry and he'd scorned her
witches are fierce though lyra said but
if she loved him well
said mary love is ferocious too
but he loved my mother said will and i
can tell her that he was never
unfaithful
lyra looking at will thought that if he
fell in love
he would be like that
completely faithful
and that is indeed what is going to be
happening soon
so we we see them together and they're
on their own in a another place
um
she takes one of the little red fruits
with a fast beating heart she turns to
him and says will and she lifted the
fruit gently to his mouth she could see
from his eyes he knew at once what she
meant and he was too joyful to speak
his fingers were still at his lips and
he felt them tremble and he put his own
hand to holders there then neither of
them could look they were confused they
were brimming with happiness
like two moths clumsily bumping together
with no more weight than that their lips
touched
then before they knew how it happened
they were clinging together blindly
pressing their faces toward each other
like mary said he whispered you know
straight away when you like someone when
you were asleep on the mountain before
she took you away i told pan
i heard she whispered i was awake and i
wanted to tell you the same and now i
know what i must have felt all the time
i love you will i love you the word love
set his nerves ablaze all his body
thrilled with it and he answered her in
the same words kissing her hot face over
and over drinking in with adoration the
scent of her body and her warm honey
fragrant hair and her sweet moist mouth
that tasted of the little red fruit
now this is going to produce
something very
important
something new happens the terrible flood
of dust in the sky stopped flowing
it wasn't still by any means mary
scanned the whole sky with the amber
lens see seeing a current here and eddie
there of vortex farther off it was in
perpetual moment movement but it wasn't
flowing away anywhere
anymore in fact if anything it was
falling like snowflakes
what had done that
the young ones said atal mary turned spy
glass in hand to see will and lyra
returning they were some ways off they
weren't hurrying they were holding hands
talking together heads close oblivious
to everything else she could see that
even from a distance she nearly put the
spy glass to her eye but held back and
returned it to her pocket
there was no need for the glass she knew
what she would see
they would seem to be made of living
gold
they would seem the true image
of what human beings always could be
once they had come into their
inheritance the dust pouring down from
the stars had found a living home again
and these children no longer children
saturated with love were the cause of it
all love has a
metaphysical and ecological import going
beyond just these two
young lovers who
have changed the course of that and a
little bit later seraphina says they did
this something happened today or
yesterday if it's after midnight mary
said trying to find the words to explain
and remembering her vision of the dust
flows a great river like the mississippi
something tiny but crucial if you wanted
to divert a mighty river into a
different course and all you had was a
single pebble you could do it
provided you put the pebble in the right
place
to send the first trickle of water this
way instead of that something like that
happened yesterday i don't know what it
was
they saw each other differently or
something and until then they hadn't
felt like that and suddenly they did
and then the dust was attracted to them
very powerfully and it started flowing
the other way
so
again a miracle is is happening you know
bringing things together
then um
after that
uh we find that you know
will and and lyra have to figure out
what they're doing what they're going to
do and she says oh will what can we do
whatever can we do i want to live with
you forever i want to kiss you and lie
down with you and wake up every day of
my life till i die
years and years and years away i don't
want a memory just a memory
no he said memory is a poor thing to
have it's your own real hair and mouth
and arms and eyes and hands i want i
didn't know i could ever love anything
so much oh lyra i wish this night would
never end if only we could stay here
like this and the world could stop
turning and everyone else could fall
into his sleep everyone else except for
us and you and i could live here forever
and just love each other and then will
says
i will love you forever whatever happens
till i die and after i die and when my i
find my way out of the land of the dead
i'll drift about forever all my atoms
until i find you again and then she says
i'll be looking for you will every
moment every single moment and when we
do find each other again we'll cling
together so tight that nothing and no
one will ever tear us apart every atom
of me and every atom of you will live in
birds and flowers and dragonflies and
pine trees and in clouds and in those
little specks of light you see floating
in sunbeams and when they use our atoms
to make new lives they won't be able to
take just one they'll have to take two
one of you and one of me will be joined
so tight
isn't this
remarkable prose
and isn't it so relatable if you've ever
felt deep love
their
diamonds come together now and they
break the taboo of not touching each
other's
diamonds
will put her hand on hers a new mood had
taken hold of him and he felt resolute
and peaceful
knowing exactly what he was doing and
exactly what it would mean he moved his
hand from lyra's wrist and stroked the
red gold fur of her diamond
lyra gasped but her surprise was mixed
with the pleasure so like the joy that
flooded through her when she had put the
fruit to his lips that she couldn't
protest because she was breathless
with a racing heart she responded in the
same way
she put her hand on the silky warmth of
will's dimon and as their fingers
tighten in the fur she knew that will
was feeling exactly what she was and she
knew too that neither diemone would
change now having felt a lover's hand on
them they were their shapes for life
they would want
no other
so we have this remarkable
you know uh love that changes the course
of this conscious matter that is dust
that
helps you know conscious beings be what
they are throughout the the multiverse
we have
lovers who you know we often say oh
you're my soul mate they actually touch
each other's souls
is this a happy ending it certainly
seems like it but it can't be a happy
ending because they
have to seal up all of the gateways and
that means that they
have to live in their own worlds because
will could live in lyra's world but he
would sicken and die by 10 years and
lyra could do the same but neither of
them want to
see their lover
waste away so they have to live in
separate worlds
and here's what we we find them doing
lyra tugs at will's hand and leads him
past a pool with a fountain under a
widespread tree then what goes off to
the left between beds of plants towards
a many trunk pines she leads him to a
wooden seat under a spreading low
branched tree
i'd hoped so much here it is just the
same will i used to come here in my
oxford and sit on this exact same bench
whenever i wanted to be alone just me
and pan what i thought is if you maybe
just once a year could come here at the
same time for an hour or something we
could pretend we were close again
because we would be close and that's all
that they have and that's where
we're going to end this
examination of these amazing books
you